playboy Playboy Hugh Hefner has died at
91 we'll examine how the Playboy
philosophy transformed America then
Arielle Davidson's Oh Rachel and his
eminence Paul Dubois joined the panel of
deplorable z' to discuss sex sex sex
half naked lady football players and
president Trump's partial-birth abortion
ban finally the mailbag in which I am
accused of idolatry and clear up much
religious confusion I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
so Hef is dead sad day said for half and
his family you know it wipes out all the
NFL news so now we have to do a whole
show about sex and I actually sort of
feel bad for Hugh Hefner when I think
about this this thought occurs to me
every time either some libertine dies or
a virtuous great man dies because you
sort of think well Hefner probably had a
lot of fun in his life he probably had
one or two one or two fun experiences at
least and he's dying with his family and
friends around him his 26 year old wife
around him and the thing that people are
gonna say about him is man he had a fun
life he had a good time I bet he had a
lot of fun but when a when a a good man
dies he's surrounded by his wife of 50
years and his memories and his children
and his friends and they say he was a
good man maybe they even say he was a
great man and it does really put things
into perspective it shows that hanging
concentrates the mind wonderfully as
they say which actually we'll get to in
a mailbag question so we have to delve
right into it because Hugh Hefner it was
a colorful character he was a lot of fun
to watch he depending on your point of
view destroyed America or you know
brought it into an Age of Aquarius but
he did have the Playboy philosophy and
here is Hef explaining the Playboy
philosophy to another sort of playboy
who William F Buckley Jr yes it comes
along about whether or not you reject
cotton mathas accretions on the Mosaic
law but whether you reject the Mosaic
law that you do you reject for instance
monogamy do you reject the notion of
sexual continence before marriage
yourself that is to say you as a
philosopher the new idea of sexual
liberation well I think what it really
comes down to it was an attempt to
establish a you know what's been called
a new morality and I really think that's
what the American you know there's this
thing called the American sexual
revolution is really all about it's an
attempt to replace the old legalism it's
certainly not a rejection of
of monogamy as such but very much an
attempt in the case of premarital sex
there really hasn't been any moral code
in the past except simply allow shalt
not and that's a code isn't it
well perhaps I don't think it's a very
realistic one it's amazing to watch
those two men who come from completely
different sides of the sexual revolution
the cultural revolution and to just look
at how they comport themselves Bill
Buckley is sort of smiling he's relaxed
he's confident he has a depth of
knowledge that he's bringing out and
then you cut to young half who who cut a
decent jib he's a fairly good-looking
guy but his brows are furrowed he seems
nervous he seems almost to have a sort
of shame on him to be discussing the
revolution that he is helping to lead
and the question that we have to ask
ourselves is what does the sexual
revolution look like 60 years later
after Hugh Hefner assured in this era
and the numbers don't look good
rape rates have tripled since 1950
according to the FBI annual crime
reports in 1965 24% of black infants
were born out of wedlock 3.1 percent of
white infants were born out of wedlock
today 72 percent of black infants are
born out of wedlock almost three times
or exactly three times rather and
twenty-nine point four percent of white
infants born out of wedlock in 1960 the
divorce rate was 22% since 1985 the
divorce rate has wavered between 40 and
50 percent more than doubled today and
more black babies are aborted than born
in New York City and porn is a five
billion dollar per year industry the
numbers are apparently four billion
dollars from in-store purchases and
another billion dollars on the Internet
this isn't the only way though to think
about sex and sexuality as Hefner says
he's reacting to Puritanism he's
reacting to prudishness but you wouldn't
call a guy like Bill Buckley exactly a
prude and here is Bill Buckley giving
another sense of of sensuality and
sexuality
it's ready but miniskirts are in good
taste on you I think they're good legs
on good like I never would have figured
you for that triangle
don't you just love the guy I pillbug I
love just sometimes just when I'm in the
shower I'll just be reading news
headlines and I'll just say it like
William F Buckley Jr
I mean where did that guy go where did
that culture go who knows but it makes
it a real point which is Bill Buckley
isn't saying go away I hate miniskirts
miniskirts are terrible and any woman
who wears them is gonna be burned in
Hell forever and we all need to wear
burqas absolutely not that isn't the
read that isn't the opposite of Playboy
ism of the Playboy philosophy the answer
is to make a little joke about it to say
yeah I like nice legs I like miniskirts
they look really good on you for the
society they're probably not a good sign
but if you're wearing one that's just
fine by me it's a it's a more human
approach and I'm not sure exactly what
Hugh Hefner was reacting against as he's
describing Puritanism in the playboy
philosophy but it isn't that he isn't
reacting against traditional traditional
sexual practices and traditional sexual
morality it seems to me that these
people they think they invented sex they
think that they invented all of this but
they didn't do that they just made it
more boring they accomplished the
impossible
you know Playboy's subscriptions have
been falling for decades they may have
been consumed in their own revolution
and they created men that aren't manly
in the real sense they might be
libertine but they're not liberated
they're not really free it reminds me of
CS Lewis's men without chests in
abolition a man he says quote you can't
go on seeing through things forever the
whole point of seeing through something
is to see something through it to see
through all things is the same as not to
see and that might be the point Hugh
Hefner says well the old sexual laws
they're outdated and ridiculous and we
need to get past them get past them to
what what is going to replace that he
says he's going to build a new morality
he didn't build a new morality he just
got rid of morality but you you can't
you can't see through things forever and
Lewis goes on quote in a sort of ghastly
simplicity we remove the organ and
demand the function we make men without
chests and expect of them
shoe and enterprise we laugh at honor
and are shocked to find traitors in our
midst we castrate and build the gelding
bid the geldings be fruitful we're
creating these men where when you have
nerd eyes I don't think a lot of people
are going to say there was a great man
there is a life well-lived will joke
about it will say I had a good life yeah
gosh I wish I had that life but we don't
really mean that this is a guy who lived
a life worth admiring we won't tell our
children do what Hugh Hefner did because
he was a man without a chest and
speaking of chests we need to get to
people who certainly have chests that
would be the lingerie football league
now I think it's now called the legend
football league or something like that
it's that's what they I guess that's
what they say it's called now but it's a
lingerie football league I actually
didn't know this thing existed until
this morning and then I did a lot of
research over my morning coffee and it's
this league where women wear skimpy
outfits and play football I guess but
they're the reason they're culturally
relevant right now is that they're
standing up for America while the NFL
player ingrates are taking a knee the
LFL the last bastion of hope for our
country is the LFL is coming out and
saying quote the LFL recognizes
everyone's First Amendment right to
protest but our nations flag and anthem
are far too sacred quote too many fellow
Americans have made the ultimate
sacrifice so that our flag and anthem
continue in all its majesty well done
ladies a great show for America really
appreciate you with that we have to
bring on our panel of deplorable z-- I I
was thinking today for this show which
is all about sex xx I figured that we
should do an all-female panel they've
told me absolutely not HR simply will
not be able to handle the complaints
that come in so instead we brought on
one female Ariel Davidson we have on zou
Rachel and His Eminence Paul Bois
everybody thank you for being here
though so can you hear me so are you
plugging your thing in we run a real
tight ship over here at the Michael NOLA
sent up during the panel
yeah yeah he was around he was doing
some research on the lingerie football
league - now I know that you're a former
lingerie league player and these women
these women are really the voice of
reason here is it time that we finally
buy into the feminist notion that women
should rule the world advice from from
Eve you know who wanted to assume
authority at that point and weird thing
is that Eve got her suggestion from
another guy so it kind of balances out
mmm that's that is true it was that
other guy who told so but what does that
have to do with my looking at the
lingerie football league this presents a
real theological problem Arielle because
that is true the blood rushes the blood
rushes away from my brain Arielle
between the Playboy philosophy and
feminism men have got it pretty good
easy sex we don't need to pick up the
check we don't have to open the door we
don't have any accountability the age of
chivalry is dead but in the age of the
Playboy philosophy how can women regain
their status wow that is a loaded
question I have a lot of feelings on it
um so I'll start when I don't know where
to start I'll start anywhere by the way
Ariel that's a great way to begin with
how women can reclaim their status I say
I just have so many feelings I am all
the feelings are rushing into me please
go ahead
alright well the first thing I will say
is what struck me about your distorted
description of the sexual revolution I
would add to that the advent of the
birth control pill played a huge role in
sort of the double standard when it came
to premarital sex for women versus men
and so I think there is a sort of
something I think that the birth control
pill needs to be given sort of its due
course um when it comes to in terms of
feminism and chivalry I think feminism
in pushing sort of the sexual revolution
of the female and more feet sexual
openness has been detrimental to how men
perceive their role in society and so I
think like you know the now the most
common image of the
is this thirtysomething year-old woman
she is probably single she's probably
having trouble finding a man who's out
her education level because women are
graduating from college at higher rates
than men are of course they might be
uneducated like everyone else who
graduates from right now you make a good
point more women are graduating there
ostensibly more educated than men they
are and so the image of the proverbial
forever single thirtysomething year-old
woman is becoming more commonplace now
and I think a lot of that has to do with
you know being able to be completely
independent also means that we haven't
created a need for men as much and you
know both men and women need to feel
needed by the opposite sex that's
ultimately I think that this thesis of
women are from Venus and men are from
Mars that you need to create some sort
of need for the opposite sexes in your
life if women can hold their own doors
if they can you know do everything
independently on their own then men sort
of feel useless and in that sense what
is the point of chivalry right if we can
do everything on our own what's the
point of needing men and vice versa you
know if men are becoming increasingly
more independent and distant and there's
not really a need for women then they
too will not feel that they need a
relationship so I will tell you though
Ariel every night as I put my head on my
pillow this is my fiancee sweet little
Lisa leans over and she does say Mack I
do not meet you I never need you and yet
the converse is not true when she goes
away for a week or two to New York my
life falls into shambles I am living
like a hog in sewage the walls are
falling down from there there's a real
double standard there right Oh is there
absolutely so she doesn't need you she's
just she's just performing her due
diligence at oranjee charity it's
cheering yeah so I guess that was a
long-winded answer but that's sort of
you know I think how feminism has killed
chivalry in a lot of ways that would be
sort of my argument at least third wave
feminism and to some extent second wave
feminism as well sure yeah and and you
you make a good point that we the what
the way out of it is to feel needed to
feel possessed to feel in need of the
other support and and and supporting the
other remnants your
obviously your view I assume you'll be
speaking ex cathedra will be infallible
Hugh Hefner was a charming guy and it's
hard not to like him
he was even apparently monogamous during
his three marriages so try to unpack
that but he does say he didn't cheat on
his wives as multiple wives how did have
go so wrong
oh well that is a very loaded question
Michael and I'm going to give my
Catholic perspective on this now I'm
gonna start with a quotes that Hugh
Hefner said in an interview in 1974 said
quote at a very early age I began
questioning a lot of that religious
foolishness about man's spirit and body
being in conflict with God primarily
with the spirit of man and the devil
dwelling in the flesh he also said part
of the reason that I am Who I am is my
Puritan roots run deep
my folks are Puritan my folks are
prohibitionists there was no drinking in
my home no discussion of sex and I think
I saw the hurtful and hypocritical side
of that from the very early on now
essentially what Hefner was operating
under in his family life well who were
Methodists is a heresy in the Catholic
Church known as Gnosticism which
completely and totally denies the flesh
and says that the flesh is evil and all
spiritual existence in relationship to
God exists primarily in the spirit
primarily in the mind and Descartes
would expand this into a philosophy
known as Cartesian philosophy so
essentially what that is is it denies
material in aiding in your salvation
process this goes back to John Calvin
John Calvin had sort of the similar
thing that all human beings are totally
depraved in matter gravity yeah total
depravity and matter as part of that so
essentially what you do when that
happens is you essentially say that
matter is essentially useless sex
becomes just a utilitarian thing it's
primarily used for procreation it's no
longer about the bonding and man and
wife coming together in multiple
different ways spiritually physically
and partaking the joy of that which also
produces a child it rejects things like
music creating Beauty creating the
for sure you think that he's reacting
just from one complete extreme all the
way over to the other exactly yes
they're two sides of the same oppressive
coin and you know Norma Connell made
this point once I think it was on some
comedy album of his he said scientists
say that men think about sex every 1.5
seconds and that he knows that isn't
true
because you know he he knows what he's
thinking about and he knows the precise
amount of time that men think about sex
which is every once in a while people
say like either were we're just
completely sex-obsessed we have to just
everything has to be Kaku peson and
lustful and sexy or we need to like all
throw on potato sacks and whip ourselves
whenever you have an impure thought and
obviously the both of those are
ridiculous yes of course and you know I
mean unfortunately you know puritanical
values have been a part of American
culture for a very long time I mean you
know Ray grandpappy's Knowles you know
for guys on the Mayflower they were
pretty religiously zealous yes I mean it
got so extreme I mean we had of course
like in the 1950s I mean why I Love Lucy
they couldn't use the word pregnant you
couldn't show a married couple I don't
use it on this show you say on son thank
you very much you couldn't use the word
pregnant I mean there are lots of things
that it goes to an extreme and when you
create that extreme you create a whole
entire another extreme and it's it's out
of balance and unfortunately part of me
says that if we ever get it back it will
just go back to another up yours Hannah
Cole extreme and it's something that
also infects the Catholic Church there
are people insects like the es s xpx
where they talk about when they have sex
with their spouse it's like they just
like they make sure all the clothes are
on and you you can't like ever and more
than two minutes and it's a sin yeah
yeah I read the books you know I'm just
confused by the homonym sex and sex
that's sex advice from Paul blah Arielle
did the Playboy philosophy win the
magazine is in doldrums subscriptions
peaked decades ago but obviously this is
huge porn epidemic porn is a gigantic
industry now it goes beamed directly to
your cell phone or your computer did
Hefner win
I think that what you know the movement
that Hefner was riding sort of the wave
on already helped to forward to the path
for that is still very much relevant I
think that technology is sort of
transformed how information is
transmitted transmitted so you know if
we look at how what's happened to
playboy as a print as if it's a company
the reason that you know subscriptions
have gone down probably has a lot to do
with how you can you don't really need
to pay for porn anymore you don't need
to pay for you know sectionals listen
images I think the internet is a
horrible thing and a wonderful thing for
a lot of different reasons um but you
know my point being that the sexual
revolution is something that Hefner I
think himself hath helped to foster and
he sort of become a cultural nigma and
think in a lot of ways he did win and I
think the person that Hef was behind
closed doors is probably very different
than the person he was and sort of like
you described earlier this
happy-go-lucky very jovial person sounds
like there was a lot more going under on
behind closed doors at his company and
just internally within his own mind um I
did want to point out there was
something I came across and an article I
think it was a New York Times piece on
him they described how in the sit during
the civil rights movement he actually
sent a black journalist by name of Alex
Haley to actually go interview the
founder of the American Nazi Party
because he wanted to explicitly make
that not that neo-nazi uncomfortable and
he wanted to expose his journal his like
very bombastic racism and I thought that
was very interesting because that's
aside if you have her that we don't
really hear as much about but he was
very forthright about having um you know
people come to the Playboy Mansion who
are people of color various different
people of different backgrounds and he
made an explicit um like effort to do
that is a lot to be said for the guy he
writes clearly more intellectual than
people give him credit for
he was bolder on some political issues
and so yeah he actually did do some good
things even if he did some good things
but he was he did do a lot of you know I
don't know there was a memoir that came
out from one of the Playboy Bunnies I
think it was like down the rabbit hole
that was pretty damning of Q as a person
and sort of lifestyle is so like I said
I think there's a balancing act here the
person q is and/or he was excuse me and
behind closed doors and he was to the
public is that true of all of us I'm
sure so are we just a bunch of prudes to
be disrespecting the half well to that I
want to say something very very serious
very something very sobering do y'all
think that Hugh Hefner's in his
afterlife right now soliciting those 72
versions to see if they can be in a
center pole for the jihadists who died
and named Islam oh he disembark there
man I was wondering did he have a
last-minute conversion to Islam I would
imagine that's true right you could just
get up there and say like this is it man
this is more of this I get this for
eternity damn nice I've heard friends I
hear they're nice now here's the thing
I think it's proof of concept that men
like to see boobies you know why because
naked women are valuable there's value
in naked women now which means that I
think it's more valuable than pay 399 to
see a naked woman you really want to
show value and a naked woman you're
flippin married and that way you have
access not just a visual of the boobies
you got access to so marriage is a
subscription well so that's the zou
Revolution rambha's Oh philosophy to
follow the Playboy philosophy a very
good one now in in related news we have
next week the Congress will vote on the
pain capable unborn child protection act
this act came up in 2015 it was shot
down now President Trump says it is a
high priority for
him to sign the bill pass it into law
and protect and and their and ban
late-term abortions so that he can
protect these unborn babies now I think
we're all probably happy about the
content of the law but it does raise a
federalism question Arielle should we be
passing these laws at a federal level or
should we leave it to the states because
I you know I'm someone who's adamantly
pro-life especially when it comes to
issues like the partial birth abortion I
am in favor of passing this on a federal
level and I'll tell you why because I
don't think there's any murky gray area
when it comes to sort of what a partial
birth abortion is I'm not going to go
into detail and spare our viewers but um
needless to say that it is something
that is violent it is gruesome
II really sorry because I was reading
about this on everyday feminism a
partial birth abortion that's when you
just take out a slight little sack of
cells that's a part of the mother
through a completely clinical and normal
procedure no not at all that's not it no
I know
horrible um basically you if you are a
woman you give partial birth to the
fetus and/or the baby let's call it baby
for what it is you give birth to the
baby it's basically half out of your
body and at which point they are allowed
to murder the child as it is halfway out
of your body the mother doesn't want it
then it's not murder right the ethics
right life is subjective bracelets
whatever you decide likes B that's the
mystery of life is Sandra Day O'Connor
would say it's so right so what you know
what bothers me about is I don't think
this is there's any gray area when it
comes to this I think this was a good
call and I support Trump in supporting
this I think we're one step closer to
creating an agenda that is much more
hostile to abortion I think what's
happened at least on the left in the
spectrum it's sort of become a cause of
celebration and I think it's disgusting
I think it's morally reprehensible and I
would you know I'm I applaud
for supporting this spam I just would
like to see it actually happen because
that in terms of defunding Planned
Parenthood that hasn't happened yet
we've yet to see that happen and so you
know this is one step closer to showing
that Trump is actually gonna follow
through and some of the things he said
during his campaign he has to walk the
walk and one point on the word fetus
people are on the Left they always try
to draw a distinction between a fetus
and a baby just as a matter of language
the word fetus means offspring so a
human fetus is human offspring it comes
from Latin it for some reason they think
it means I don't know like unicorn or
something but it does mean offspring
there's no difference between those
words so Democrats defeated this bill
two years ago do the Democrats really
believe that being the party of killing
sentient nation human life is a winning
campaign platform well convenience is
popular you know and and when it comes
to Democrats that's what they're all
about you know you a majority rule it
things in you get a majority by things
being popular and a popular thing is
convenience so of course it's gonna do
well well for lack of a better word for
them politically to be opposed to
something like that but if I may can I
answer a question the question about you
know whether it should be handled on a
federal level or state level absolutely
no no way yeah I'm sorry go ahead please
it's very simple we have a supreme law
of the land and we all have to live
under it and we all have the right to
life liberty pursuit of happiness you
can't make a decision on this on state
level this this isn't even a question of
a ship in court or not because you're
taking the court to actually to deprive
somebody of their rights you live that's
not something that the court would be
like what we're not going to do a
hearing on that that's ridiculous so
even on a state level
it offers if the state decided to make
it legal then the federal government has
the right to come in and say actually no
you're imposing on somebody's right to
live that is when the government is
close to be involved I think we're all
limited government people here yeah
absolutely
but the the objective of government is
to protect our god-given rights so
should this be a question of this job
maybe in the States
no I'm not in the most fundamental right
is
right to life so if you don't have that
you can't have a limited can have the
rest without them wah wah this is
definitely a step in the right direction
yes but what about all those unborn
babies who are aborted before they are
capable of feeling pain do you think is
a matter of politics or morality the
Conservatives should fight this abortion
fight later on in second third trimester
where there is broad support for banning
abortion or should conservatives be
logically consistent and say we just
need to outlaw abortion overturn roe v
wade human life is sacred from the
beginning yes I certainly oh yeah I
certainly believe I'm an absolutist on
this I mean if I were president I would
sign an executive order right away and
just declare that roe v wade was
complete crap and it's gone as the
monarch monarch is Pablo is the
monarchists in me yes but so just on a
political level obviously if I'm in a
Senate and they bring forth this bill of
course I'm going to sign onto it and and
support anything that protects human
life but I do think that the pro-life
movement and this you know on the
grassroots level they have this voice
it's certainly not you know on the
political level but absolutely I am an
absolutist just say it let's end it
completely totally abortion is evil it
is it's the worst moral scourge to
happen to this country since slavery and
we just need to voice it as much as
possible
every day until the public finally gets
the message the pro-life generation of
my my generation is pro-life takes that
very seriously but the people you know
baby boomer is people who were around
when abortion came onto the scene they
don't really have that intensity but the
younger generation really does because
we see it's fallout we see true and when
the Boomers also gave us a terrible
national debt that we'll never be able
to pay but that's neither here nor there
I'm sorry though we cut you off no no I
I thought the question was for me but it
was for kiss in minutes sorry about that
absolutely I'll go ahead I know I was
just gonna say as well that I think
technology is on our side too here in
the 70s when you know roe v wade came
about they didn't have that
ecology that we have now we can look in
and see you know elements of the child
that we never would have been able to
see prior you can see fingernails we can
see hands we can see toes I mean these
are the certain things that you just
wouldn't you know this is something that
will it shouldn't be that we need to see
it to believe its life that's not my
point but if we're trying to make people
understand what we're fighting for that
is really a powerful weapon and that's
in our core and that's in our favor and
I can already start to see people on the
left sort of shaking in their boots as
more and more science comes out about
how sentient the baby is at a really
really young age stage of development
and it's amazing because Shapiro said he
there was a great little viral video
going around from his last speech where
he said it doesn't the sentience doesn't
matter we shouldn't be able to kill
someone in a coma and it right there is
this point that I think when we bring up
all of the scientific advancements that
let us see the unborn baby I think well
fingernails aren't the reason we have a
right to life you're the reason people
have a pacemaker or whatever but it is
politically and emotionally very
compelling so so should we rely on it
for that reason
I mean you know it's tough because
that's like I said before I don't want
it you know I shouldn't be saying oh
we're gonna quantify life but what but
what by what we can see but maybe if it
will help us to start the conversation
then I'm all for that because at this
point it's about reaching people in a
way that we can show them okay this is
what you're actually killing because now
in certain states you don't even need to
have you don't even need to have an
ultrasound before you go through an
abortion you don't even need to engage
at all with the child you've created
before you decide to kill it and so in
my mind that's horrible I don't want to
see it before you kill the thing that's
right right absolutely not you don't
want to walk it's just it's awful anyway
not you know I have obviously have a ton
of sympathy for the women that go
through with this I know it's not an
easy choice but when it comes down to
having a conversation about when life
begins and trying to make people
understand what we're fighting for you
know I'm in favor of using technology to
do that as long as that's not our main
line of argument I mean my environment
should always be like
conception yeah and you might say it's a
simple choice but not an easy choice
that distinction that Ronald Reagan drew
said there aren't easy answers but there
are simple answers it is clear it's just
very difficult to accept the implication
that human life is sacred from the
beginning absolutely right okay panel
man what a what a serious show all I
wanted to talk about was lingerie ladies
and sex but you've brought me back down
to ideas and things like that thank you
for being here Arielle Davidson His
Eminence Paul Bois and the one and only
so Rachel now it is time for the mailbag
okay now I think we should probably say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube here
we've got these great questions for the
mailbag we have I'm accused of idolatry
and Catholic idolatry one of them so
we'll be answering that but you cannot
see it unless you go over and subscribe
at the daily wire.com
I know you really want but I'm sorry I
it's it's not up to me we thank
everybody who's a current subscriber
they help us keep the lights on for the
rest of you it's ten bucks a month 100
dollars a year and what do you get you
get no ads on the website that's very
helpful you get my show you get the
Andrew Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show yeah yeah yes so what but
guys guys come on you get the leftist
tears tumblr the indestructible leftist
here's tumblr made from crushed up and
hardened bit reinforced bits of steven
crowder mugs it is housing wonderful
vintages this year we have NFL players
we have George Clooney
we have Hillary Clinton every single one
of her tweets fills up a full tumblr
full of delicious tears so go over there
right now
daily wire calm we'll be right back
all right the first mailbag question is
from RA hey Michael I love your show and
I really love how many people you bring
onto the show thank you a recent poll
showed that over 60% of Trump supporters
say that they will support anything that
Trump says does this poll worry you why
or why not it does where I'm really
worried about the other 40% what about
those guys why aren't they pulling their
fair heart and supporting our our party
in our president no I'm I am not really
worried about this demagoguery and this
week in particular showed it to me the
victory of Roy Moore in Alabama over
Luthor strange in the Senate primary for
the special election President Trump
endorsed Luthor strange the Rhoyne war
was a more Trumpy candidate he ran the
Kofi faher campaign and the people of
that state voted for more they they gave
more the nomination instead I don't
think it's because they don't like
President Trump in Roy Moore his victory
speech he said I don't care the Trump
didn't endorse me I support his agenda
100% as long as it's constitutional so I
think what that shows is Ann Coulter's
thesis that there's the support for
Trump is based on issues it's based on
what he's doing it's based on a
fortitude to take on sacred cows and
revered left-wing cultural institutions
and beat him up and stand firm unlike a
lot of spineless Republicans so there is
a difference between the Trump movement
and Donald Trump it isn't just a
mindless cult of personality like we
think I don't really believe the 60%
number but in any case if we do then
then you know I think these numbers
change a lot because political polls are
constantly constantly changing next
question from Jake Michael where can we
watch your movie Hollyweird thanks love
the show so I am I've been in a bunch of
these little indie movies that play at
like 3:00 in the morning on Channel five
thousand but there is one movie where I
have the lead role in it and right now
it's at the festival circuit it's called
Hollyweird I'm hoping that it will be
able to have some sort of public viewing
of it soon either a screening in
theaters or on video on demand or
something
like that but I'll keep you posted it's
a really fun movie coincidentally this
has nothing to do with my political work
but it is a movie that just lambaste
Hollywood so I think everyone is gonna
like it a providential coincidence next
question is from Johnny Miguel just
watched your interview with Dave Ruben
I enjoy his videos and honesty in his
opinions however I'm not gonna lie when
he was discussing the he/she pronoun
controversy and the courtesy it was a
bit cringy he seemed to be making a
large push for the emotional aspect of
the argument which comes off as weak all
this is to ask are we entering a new
rabbit hole where we will have to give
up sanity and in 20 years accept new
pronouns into our language if so how can
we combat this yeah I disagree with Dave
on this I'm I am stuck with the question
of how to be polite and courteous and a
gentleman and also not mainstream
delusion and pretend that reality is
unreality and allow delusional people to
try to define reality for the rest of us
and call it bigotry if we don't buy into
their madness I think he's wrong about
this because Dave is a liberal he's a
classical liberal he believes in the
liberal a mode of decision-making which
is where I'm gonna we're gonna
vigorously debate ideas in public and
the best ideas hopefully will come to
the top but I think on this particular
issue he's falling into what Jonathan
Roush calls the humanitarian impulse of
decision-making which is the first
consideration when you're making a
decision is how not to offend people
it's how to make people feel nice about
themselves and not not harm them which i
think is ultimately harmful I think the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions
so we might try to call someone whatever
they want to be called but if we're not
dealing in reality then we're removing
them from reality and it's I think
condescending and and it doesn't help
them to see the real world any better
Shapiro's also on this once said I think
it was his grandfather had a mental
illness and they got him medicine they
didn't they didn't say that the radio
really was talking to him they just got
him medicine and and I think that's
where the focus should be on that
question next question is from father
Greg father Greg a priest dear Michael
the once in future came trolls I'm
monthly subscribers so I don't have a
leftist ears tumblr sorry but can you
answer a question for me I'm a Catholic
priest wit were I to attempt to bless
left as tears what would happen with the
tears a do nothing as leftist tears are
already a maximal blessing be reject the
blessing as since action follows being
the leftist tears possessing the
character of the leftist are thus not
properly disposed to receive the
blessing or see Kofi Fey in Sayaka
Lusaka lorem I am awed by the
perspicacity of your arguments and the
insight in this question all I can say
to you Father is a spare jsm a hot air
he saw paul moon table that that line is
going to land for about five people in
this audience but that's what we do we
just go right for them most niche punch
like we can do people were laughing at
that joseph michael i wanted to know
your stance on the death penalty what
your stance on the death penalty is as a
catholic I'm also Catholic but I keep
getting told some of my friends with the
same faith that we should never take the
lives of criminals and less not doing so
threatens the security of others what do
you think
I think that's total bunk man I don't
believe that at all Joseph I think
that's a relatively modern Catholic
stance and it's promoted by people who
are doing it in the name of the Catholic
faith but not necessarily with the
backing of that tradition obviously st.
Paul says that the civil authority has
the right to do whatever its it pleases
basically whatever it does lawfully and
the Catholic Church the Catechism
acknowledges that the death penalty is
not an intrinsic evil and that it is
rightly part of the state's authority it
says later that quote today would be
rare if practically non-existent because
there is less threat of these criminals
going back out and killing people we can
keep them in these expensive
institutions which to me seems more
cruel and unusual than killing them a
father Rutner whom I often cite points
out in a wonderful column called hanging
concentrates the mind quo
as a highly unusual insertion of a
prudential opinion in a catechetical
formula it would seem to be more
mercurial and application than the
doctrine of the legitimacy of the death
penalty it's a little rare and it's a
little strange that in the Catechism
they offer this opinion about when it
would be used or wouldn't be used and so
one wonders what the status of that is
compared to the clear statement that the
civil authority has the right to kill
people
rattler also points out the medicinal
benefits of capital punishment
dr. Johnson famously said dependent
bonnet sir when a man knows he is to
hang in a fortnight it concentrates his
mind wonderfully and the health benefit
of being killed by the government is of
course that the criminal can focus his
mind he can think of eternal things and
the condemned have a frame of mind to
die in a state of grace so yeah I
support the death penalty I don't think
the Catholic faith condemns it and you
should go right on considering that the
civil authority has the right to exact
justice a topic that is largely missing
from our criminal justice system and
criminology today from raymond another
catholic question but this this one's
pretty good Michael since you're a
Catholic allow me to ask this why do
y'all worship false idols I know the
candle burning is from African voodoo
but saints elected by men Mary isn't
divine you can't gain admission to
heaven through your works you do good
works because you are godly and saved
why do you call priests father they're
not your father God is the father then
you have an earthly father but priests
aren't him
sounds pretty contrary to Christianity I
don't know if Raymond is just some arch
Catholic who's trolling me with this
with this letter but maybe not there's a
lot of confusion about the Catholic
faith I think that's why the majority of
the mailbag questions are about that so
let's go through all of your objections
Raymond and I will dispel your confusion
beginning with candle burning as some
part of African voodoo the fluorescent
light bulb is a relatively new invention
for most of history
everybody everyplace used candles to
light the way and by the way candle
light gives off a much more beautiful
then does Alborz stupid light bulbs with
mercury on them so I think the candles
are fine I don't think it's confined to
African voodoo I think it's the way to
illuminate the world other than the Sun
and the Sun of God Saints are not
elected by men that's absolutely true
very often people say well Catholics
worship Saints and that's idolatrous or
polytheistic or something
Saints are those who have everlasting
life in Christ
Saints are referred to in many instances
in the Bible and the church acknowledges
that certain people are Saints through a
process called canonization so that's
not all the Saints there are more people
in heaven than the church is called
Saints but some we know are in heaven
and the way we know this is because of
the Magisterium of the church that is
based on a number of scriptural
instances but in particular Jesus says
to Peter you are Peter and on this rock
I will build my church whatever you bind
in heaven of whatever you bind on earth
will be loosed by bound in heaven
whatever you loose on earth will be
loosed on it in heaven you have the keys
to the kingdom of heaven so there is an
authority that Christ is giving to Peter
and and then to the Apostles to have
some say and to to bind and to loose and
have the keys to the kingdom of heaven
so by definition Saints have everlasting
life
we ask Saints to pray for us now
sometimes people say you're praying to
the Saints you're worshiping the Saints
that isn't the case we ask people to
pray for us all the time we go in and we
say hey you know Bob is having surgery
next week can you pray for us hey I'm
going through a rough time please keep
me in your thoughts and prayers what
you're asking for is a sort of
intercession but you're asking it to
regular old fallen crummy people you're
asking me to pray for you I'm not even
Catholic
I know I am well I'm praying for
Marshall really for many reasons not
just as heresy and so why would you be
comfortable asking Joe Schmo to pray for
you but you're not comfortable of asking
people that we know have life by
definition there a lot there the people
who are living they have everlasting
life
it doesn't seem to make a lot of sense
to me I think it's a just a
misunderstanding of what it means to
pray next point Raymond has is Mary
isn't divine that's true the church has
never said Mary is divine sure we agree
your I think that's a straw man you
can't gain admission to heaven through
your works yeah it's also right the
church has never held that you can gain
admission to heaven through your works
the churches actually explicitly
condemned this as a heresy this was a
fifth century
it was it was a heresy developed in the
fifth century by Pelagius the Pelagian
heresy why do we call priests father
only God is the father if we call anyone
else other than our daddies father then
that's diminishing God I don't see any
scriptural basis for this at all the
Bible is replete with examples of people
being referred to as father who are not
literally the parents of children but
who are in positions of spiritual
authority and responsibility just to go
through a few in Genesis Genesis 45 8 so
it was not you who sent me here but God
and he has made me a father to Pharaoh
and Lord of all his house and ruler over
all the land of Egypt that's Joseph in
job I was a father to the poor and I
searched out the cause of him whom I did
not know in Isaiah in that day I will
call my servant le Hakeem the son of
Hilkiah and I will clothe him with a
robe and will bind a girdle on him and
will commit authority to his hand and he
shall be a father to the inhabitants of
Jerusalem into the house of Judah and
finally st. Paul and first Corinthians
says I do not write this to make you
ashamed but to admonish you as my
beloved children for though you have
countless guides in Christ you do not
have many fathers for I became your
father in Christ Jesus through the
gospel I don't think that all of those
scriptural examples are heresy or
blasphemous or disrespectful to God at
all you know one aspect of this where it
ties back to politics is I reject
ideologies per se obviously we indulge
them a little bit but the one thing I
know about ideologies is that they're
not true the reason that ideologies are
not true is because they're rationalized
abridgements of tradition of reality
they can't possibly comprehend all of
reality and so the one thing that I know
about religious sects founded by men is
that they aren't true
they're untrue because I can understand
them and if I can understand them then
they aren't they aren't true they're
clearly founded by men I can't
I can understand Calvinism I cannot
understand the Catholic Church which for
many people would be the reason why they
would be Calvinists for me it's the
reason I'm a Catholic because if I can't
understand it then there's a fair shot
it wasn't founded by men if Noah nobody
in history has really been able to
encapsulate and understand this thing
it's good evidence that perhaps it was
as it says instituted by Christ on earth
GK Chesterton converted to Catholicism
for precisely this reason he said that
all these different sects are attacked
for being too conservative or too
left-wing or to this or to that but only
the Catholic Church is attacked for both
at the same time it's attacked from all
sides which might suggest that it has
the the right idea and just to hit this
point because a lot of the questions you
brought up I think could be answered
with a Google result I google these
things all the time if you're worried is
that something isn't clear then I think
you should look a little harder because
shallows are clear shallow religion is
clear shallow thinking is clear profound
things are deep and murky that isn't my
line that's the line of father rut ler
it makes a very good point if something
is so clear that you or I can understand
it I'm skeptical skeptical of it and I
think we should approach our politics
and certainly our human interactions and
absolutely our are off or God with that
same humility on that note I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt Rai to
survive the weekend we will be back on
Monday and I will see you then
[Music]
[Music]